[Music]
i love that dog nike making another
appearance on draft day
anything that humanizes bill belichick
because there is a human being in there
somewhere you just don't see it very
often because it could be used against
him it's that military mindset that he
brings to football and he keeps his
cards close to the vest but it's nice to
see bill with his dog
uh and they got their quarterback they
got the quarterback that
that
many thought the 49ers had traded up to
get all right number three
many who are those people who who
thought that what did you thought
many were saying
that mac jones was the pick
and
it really is amazing to me
that the 49ers
now claim
it wasn't
and that they just kind of sat back and
watched it all they studied it all as
some sort of a sociological experiment
as to how people would talk about it and
what they would say and what they would
do and they didn't feel compelled to
push back on it at all i think that's a
mistake from a pr standpoint because
you'll want to set your fans
expectations and there is a way there is
a way
to
to get
to get everybody behind it
right right you want everyone to be
behind what you're gonna do and i don't
know maybe they like the fact that the
reaction from a lot of the fans that
they were
drafting this guy who looks a little
doughy and his uniform doesn't fit right
and the prevailing attitude was what's
the deal with mac jones why does
everyone love mac jones maybe they maybe
they thought hey we'll go through that
because they'll be happy when we don't
take mac jones i don't know but
i just don't think you passively sit
back
and just watch how the news affects the
perception of your team and say hmm
that's interesting i think you have to
actively be involved in how your team is
being talked about and how your team's
being perceived but nevertheless they
now claim reportedly
that
it was never jones the jones was the
safety net in the event that their deep
dives with justin fields and trey lance
the two guys they were focused on when
they traded up again this is the report
from jim trotter of nfl media who spoke
to jed york reported this as actual fact
that it was lance and fields that they
targeted when they traded up with jones
as the
again if we decide these two guys just
don't have it then he'll be the guy that
we take
um i i don't know what to believe
anymore about anything either we had we
had said
that once the pick was made they would
act like that was their guy all along
now this
puts a little bit of a twist on that
that it could have been fields
or lance
and then they continued their deep dive
but i i
i just don't know what to make of it and
and i don't know what to make of jed
york admitting that they let frank gore
have a voice
in this process and they sent frank gore
trey lance video and he loved trey lance
i don't
i did i didn't know that frank gore was
a quarterback expert
uh it just that was an
it was an odd wrinkle
an odd wrinkle yeah an odd wrinkle that
that they would export in any way the
decision-making process to a guy that
played for them at running back and did
a really good job and they still really
like i don't know what that does to make
people feel better about the pick it
just seemed like a strange thing to add
well it's a strange thing to do they're
they seem like they're you know
post-draft trying to frame the narrative
of what was really going on before the
draft now like that you know again i
don't know if i'm gonna buy all that
that mac jones wasn't in the running of
all that now hey they could sit back and
listen to public perception and and hear
all the argument there because really
the only negative thing that was coming
out of san francisco was don't take mac
jones so that's easy to sell that to
your fan base right now right i mean oh
the guys you the guy that you all were
ready to jump off the golden gate bridge
for we weren't going to take him don't
worry don't worry so yeah you know so
it's an easy thing at this point hey i
mean i don't i don't know i don't doubt
that maybe fields and lance were the
guys they were looking at certainly you
know as we talked about i mean with
shanahan i think he's got to be
intrigued with both of those guys about
what they can bring
you know to the table as runners and
like you talked about earlier with the
kirk cousins stuff off the schedule
throwing and those type of things that's
where fields and lance certainly have an
advantage over mac jones with that type
of stuff there's no doubt so
uh
again i don't know what to think with
this either it was
a very controversial pick certainly and
we just heard so many rumors coming up i
mean listen yeah i thought i knew my
friend and thought it was mac jones
obviously i was wrong but like hey adam
schefter he also thought it was mac
jones he's been very close to the
shanahan family before too so that's
where i wrote a book with mike well
that's where i get it to go i think it's
a hard time for me to think it wasn't
even mac jones in the conversation but
here's where the 49ers are really going
to deal with like the blowback i think
more than anything and this is uh to me
this is the thing that you know i heard
around the league this weekend
was the big thing is
more than anything here
is
did they really have to trade up to
number three to do this that's that's
the real conversation that's the thing
that's going to be judged and we're
going to judge trey lance versus justin
fields and mac jones and compare them we
know that but the other thing you can
come away from after watching the draft
and i know there's
is that
yeah did they really have to do that did
you have to go up to number three in the
end of march
and make a trade move like that right
then now i've i've been told by two
different teams that
you know that that uh that david uh no
i'm jimmy sexton was right before the
draft incredibly concerned that if the
49ers don't take treylands because he
still didn't know if they were he didn't
know where he was going to go he was
calling around the league trying to find
a spot so that's where it could just
look bad on the 49ers when all said and
done is the fact that they moved up nine
spots and gave up three first round
picks when when you just come away from
the first round and you can look at it
and go i think he might have just fell
to you at 12 or maybe you could have
traded up to number eight i don't know
if you had to go to number three to do
all this stuff
here's the thing yeah if they would have
started into the draft
at 12 right
they wouldn't have been a team that we
would have pegged
clearly as
quarterback spot yeah you know we would
have speculated that thinking about life
yeah right right just like with the
vikings there was talk that they were
looking at justin fields and maybe
that's why the bears moved up would the
bears have felt compelled
would the bears have taken trey lance if
they had moved to 11
instead of justin fields that's what we
won't know the answer to it's kind of
like the daniel jones thing from two
years ago when the giants had two
first-round picks one at seven right was
it six or seven seven seven and then
and then in the middle of the round
and dave gettleman the gm of the team
was criticized harshly for not waiting
to take jones with that second
first-round pick and he said i guarantee
you somebody would have taken him in
between well
peter king has said he couldn't find a
team that would have taken daniel jones
in between not that anyone is going to
admit that kind of stuff they usually
don't but you can't account for the fact
that somebody would have jumped the
giants and so
maybe i i you know the 49ers would have
had fields or lance at 12. the the only
thing that that trade did was it wiped
out the possibility that they that's all
it did right right one of them right and
is it worth giving up two future first
round picks
to buy that peace of mind i don't think
it is chris i really don't think it is
that with shanahan and the quality of
the coach he is
you you keep those first round picks
you hope you get
lance or fields and if you don't
you'll find another way you'll you'll
you'll you'll find another quarterback
you'll find another way and i don't know
how much of this is making up for the
fact that they didn't properly look at
my homes in 2017
and and take him when they could have
and how much of it is resonating within
the organization that they could have
had tom brady last year and they
politely told him no thank you we're
sticking with jimmy g and then tom brady
goes and wins the super bowl and i i've
plenty of 49ers fans that said oh
there's that wouldn't have happened in
san francisco oh too many injuries to me
look you can't you can't tell me the
year would have unfolded the same way
with tom brady or you don't know no you
don't know but look at what look at what
he did for the buccaneers who were seven
and nine
the year before
and
what were the 49ers they were a super
bowl team they were the super bowl
runner up the year before so i think
that is tormenting
john lynch kyle shanahan others in the
organization that may be one of the
reasons why they did it they're done
worrying about mahomes they're done
worrying about brady we don't want to
spend the next month
worrying whether or not we're going to
get one of these quarterbacks let's just
go ahead and do it yeah maybe and then
listen i'm never mad at a team you know
like for the giant scenario
i'm not mad at a team ever like that
yeah we got a guy we
this is who we believe in we're gonna go
get it yeah it was an expense only thing
is is hey playing the draft is playing
the value of the draft too you know that
that's
that's the that's part of the task part
of the craftsmanships of you know
building your team the right way and all
that that's that's where it's just gonna
put more pressure on the situation as
lance plays or gets evaluated and all of
those type of things
and you know i still just always come
back to yes mahomes like you talked
about you know did brady not go in there
and all that last year them saying no
all that yeah it seems like it's all
come to a head to make them like you
know do something aggressive at the
quarterback position and i will still
always go back to that you know josh
allen 49ers game this past season where
you could just tell the the 49ers
coaching staff was
a little taken back by how talented josh
allen was and how much he did off
schedule and do those type of things and
to your point i think that's probably
part of the what he sees with trey lance
too he can do that type of stuff and now
he can do
what i expect he drafts aaron banks in
the second round a really awesome guard
from notre dame they're they're going
all in on a san francisco style lamar
jackson trey lands type offense that's
what i think they're going to do going
here forward it's just going to be
is he gonna start the year
are we gonna do
taste some hill platooning
like with jimmy garoppolo
my only thing with trey lance and i
listen you know i have my concerns i
know there's high end talent that i
really like too he's got to play he's
got to play that's his one of his
biggest issues is he hasn't played so i
just would be like hey friend kyle
shanahan you got to find a way to get
them in the on the field this year you
can't have them sit out of football
another gear that that to me would be
risky in itself too so i'm just
interested to see their their plan of
approach or their plan of attack here
sorry
kyle spoke with peter king and the full
quote is in football morning in america
but
he really peeled back the curtain a bit
on the process of
watching film and having opinions and
then pivoting to trying to come up with
negatives and then ultimately going back
to
the beginning and
he admits that he could watch two hours
and get himself to like anyone
uh and he loved trey lance from the
get-go that was in january and he spent
time
trying to tear him down
and none of that stuck when he got back
to the end he said he felt the way that
he originally felt about the trey lance
tape so he saw something there
that makes him and that's where the
that's where the risk comes into play
because he only played one game last
year
and it wasn't good
fcs level right double a level now
carson wentz
i don't know is carson wentz a guy that
you want to say well he went to the nfl
and he did something
i i still the book's still not written
on carson wentz he started off great too
injury-prone too banged up
uh and then lost his fastball last year
but you know that's part of the risk you
take when you dip down one level in
college football you assume that that
skill
set that you see unfold is going
to stand out when it's nfl caliber
defensive players not one double a fcs
guys and i i don't know i don't know how
many years you'd have to be a scout to
truly account
for how this guy looks against that
level of college football
versus how he will look against nfl
caliber and we're gonna find out yeah
we're gonna find out it's it's a great
situation for trey lands he's got a
great way about him i mean he's
incredibly charismatic you know anything
you hear from anybody the one thing like
trey lance all the intangibles are off
the charts so yeah there's the questions
on the field and all that but you know
man when you talk about being a young
quarterback and you got a talented
offense around you and maybe the most
talented play designer in all of
football he's going to be put in
position to succeed a lot and shanahan's
going to find ways to really crack the
cro the crack the code on defenses now
that he's got a running quarterback like
this with his running offense now paired
with this oh wow that's where it can be
really dangerous and scary and i can see
the logic of shanahan going with this
because he's going to give defensive
coordinators nightmares about wait i've
already had nightmares trying to stop
his normal run game now he's got an
extra blocker with a quarterback who can
run the ball and do all of that it's
going to cause some issues and i i would
think you know that that might help
accelerate the process to get trey lance
out there and play him and start him
early in the year
and you know
hopefully they can get to that point to
where they trade jimmy garoppolo and
they can just let jim traylands go
now the draft is over you will see a
proliferation of draft grades
my standard approach for every team
after the draft is incomplete because
that's the truth we don't know
we never know because so many of the
guys for whatever reason work and so
many don't work we know that the bust
rate roughly 50 percent some guys become
stars some guys become forgotten
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports